I have a sneaky feeling we're going to
be late so I gotta we gotta rush you
hope you win make sure everything's are
gonna win yeah all right let's see you
go please go good morning welcome to DC
but more turn to Disney World this book
again they say keep Caymans eating what
are you eating haha hot dog and Syrians
and support it Stephanie and gesture
you're eating hot dogs an egg you know
yummy breakfast and then head up to the
game so we are not late I'm excited so
we have a history of being linked for
the Blue Jays game mostly because of
Florida traffic the gps says is going to
take an hour and a half to get there and
it takes us like three so the first two
years we were late the third year we got
there just as it was starting this is
our fourth year I have a sneaky feeling
are going to be late so I gotta we gotta
rush we gotta rush we gotta rush let's
go get some starbucks and rush rush rush
to the baseball game
[Music]
Xena is in bad need of coffee coffee and
there's only one starbucks between here
and where we're going so we stop here
every year for the fourth year in a row
to get a coffee for celebrating left oh
okay yeah let's go get some gavi we got
our coffee Nina got a grande pipe very
excited about it Dylan else who you know
I don't
it's news like cream cybex haven't got a
venti caramel macchiato here hmm
hold the couch but check with guy back
in the car let's go go go to the
baseball game
we stopped in for a compromise the
chick-fil-a I'm going to hustle nema got
chicken fingers they basically all got
chicken fingers and I got a second
burger and we going to leave in five
minutes to get to the baseball game
whatever you don't finish to bring you
in the car
[Music]
ha
[Music]
all right we made it we parked around
our way in what seemed is doing are you
blocking it out call me Molly okay
everybody get it okay he's going to win
today let's hope right let's go let's
see it Nina's worried that it's going to
rain singing pretty night oh no no rain
no rain look at those clear skies that's
amazing it's all sunny up there
beautiful Florida sunshine right Nina
yeah that wasn't a rain job that was
just love juice from the sky holy [ __ ]
there is there's no root beer what does
in Toronto yeah if it rains to get wet
[Music]
so he meant did a weather check and 4pm
we're starting we're still in line for
though might get rained on okay little
for the ring I want to be inside now
[Music]
what happened to me thanks haha anything
in the southeast a happy they won't let
it bring in a selfie stick look like a
weapon kind of like aa smell like a wet
you can be violent a time I just know
successful it's this beautiful sunny
weather here is with her selfie stick in
a bush so who's got to go find it after
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay Hayden share choose your weapon
which is your favorite weapon so we
accept your power I shoot camera and
then when it is pretty powerful anything
thank you upstairs oh wow ginger what
are you guys having when ice cream break
how is it and when successfully okay
thank you okay let's go back what do we
think guys okay yeah how successfully
all right good get back to our seats
these are winning here UOP win make sure
he thinks you're going to win yes very
close all right let's see you go please
go whose is one now we got to keep it in
Geneva selfie stick to see to see the
bush just until we do it's like it's
gone you know helping sick warm up to
buy a new one what at least two days one
time to go home so I'm gonna rain its
food
[Music]
[Music]
got so hungry that i forgot the film and
let you guys know what we're eating he
made some awesome food look at those
pork chops and some special pasta
spinach and pasta and carrots and
mushrooms Oh Satan Oh even is good yeah
it's the end of day two again we kind of
forgot this film what do you don't you
looking at yourself you got to fill not
to dinner what did we do we cleaned up
you thing that I cleaned up I put the
kids to bed yeah I gave them about they
get them there fast thank you because it
back well I hope and I've been
researching the health benefits of green
tea I kind of went down this rabbit hole
tonight of the research in green tea and
the benefit how to determine a good
green tea this is a bad one good looking
at different green teas I want to get
back
quite lucky glossy I married the glossy
Chinese person you're shiny yeah Nina
shines in all situation goodbye all have
a great night thank you for joining us
today to tomorrow we start off at disney
day 3 by hitting up getting off early at
a car before you could believe whatever
you want where is whiskey to me this is
by